all right i think you're really gonna
like this clip or at least be horrified
by it in a sense that will be sort of
enjoyable but horrifying um we've talked
about the kind of like manufactured
nature
of the culture wars that the wright is
currently engaged in and the manufacture
manufactured can mean a couple different
things manufactured can be manufactured
by
creating irrational fear
um
through
lying to people and making them think
that something is a threat to their way
of life or to their family or whatever
so it could be manufactured with lies to
create fear um it can also be considered
manufactured in that it's sort of like
just based on either misunderstandings
or
factual discrepancies like about the
2020 election the big lie it's
unconstitutional
and states violated the rules and dead
people voted
and mike pillow has access to voting
machines that show you all these
different things
and it becomes sort of a cultural thing
where even though you might say well
what's the culture of claiming the
election was lost it's this cultural
fight where they see themselves as
engaged in a war
where it doesn't matter if they
literally believe the explanations as to
how the election was stolen
they see repeating that it was stolen as
being on the right team and fighting
this holy war of sorts quite frankly
one of the flashpoints so many of the
flashpoints in this include critical
race theory
war on christmas
communism and socialism coming to
america
um
you could you could argue the biden
dementia thing is part of the culture
battle
um the big lie certainly there's a whole
list of these things and we we can go on
and talk about them critical race theory
is particularly interesting because even
more pr in in an even more pronounced
way than with socialism and communism
the people talking about it don't even
know what it means oh all the vaccine
stuff also would be another element of
this a lot of the people saying critical
race theory is just a disaster they
literally have no idea what it is they
have no idea what it means they don't
understand what it means in context out
of context they just have no clue
this is a video that has gone viral
from the good liars who do these really
really great interviews the good liars
interviewed a virginia voter as many of
you know today is election day in
virginia we're going to be covering the
results live of the gubernatorial race
terry mcauliffe versus um uh uh glenn
younkin who's the republican candidate
very important race and there are really
important issues at stake the good liars
went and interviewed this guy uh
air force veteran at least according to
the hat the guy is wearing and said
what's the most important issue and the
guy said it's critical race theory and
when asked what it is the guy literally
has no idea what it is he just doesn't
know what's going on take a look at this
what's the most important issue in the
governor's race here in virginia getting
back to the basics of teaching children
not teaching them critical race theory
now
before even getting to the question what
is critical race theory
it's not very small government
conservativey
to want the governor
to necessarily dictate school curriculum
i mean remember these republicans claim
to have this principle they abide by
which is you only involve government in
everything when absolutely necessary if
not you leave things leave it to school
boards leave it to municipalities leave
it right but here
they want to elect glenn younkin who has
made a big deal out if we got to get
critical race theory out and all these
different things
completely in violation of their
so-called
light touch conservative principles but
then here comes the question what is
critical race theory and uh and what is
critical race theory
i'm not going to get into the specifics
of it because i don't understand it that
much but it's something that i don't
the what little bit that i know i don't
care for and and what have you heard
that you don't well i'm not i'm not
gonna
you know
i don't uh
i don't i don't have that much knowledge
on it but it's something that i'm not
that i don't care for you know this is
like when a kid
is presented with
you know broccolini for the first time
and the kid says
i don't like it i'm not trying it but
what about it don't you like you it
doesn't it doesn't taste good or you
don't like the tech
i've never tried it i don't like it i
don't want it
okay right but what
i don't care for it the little i know
about it which is the fact that you're
trying to feed it to me
not good
i don't like it
it's a similar dynamic well maybe inform
yourself about what it is first and our
friend anna casparian over at the young
turks had a really good tweet about
sort of another aspect so how many
layers are there to this there's a lot
of layers there's people who are just
goaded into culture war issues by fear
and propaganda that's one aspect two the
general incompetence of the american
public which we will get to in the
voicemail segment
three is what anna tweeted which is this
is what manufactured culture wars
meant to distract you from elites
robbing this country blind
results in and folks like this guy they
would probably
agr if a republican says
corporations are robbing you blind they
would probably agree in some general
sense to the extent that they understand
it
um if a republican said
you know even climate change is an issue
of patriotism like they would go for it
but very quickly all of those
substantive issues
including issues on which there aren't
big differences between republicans and
democrats who are part of the same
system that is not working for tens of
millions if not more of americans
they get distracted with something like
critical race theory which this guy even
admits that he doesn't even know what it
means so
sad
funny depressing
kafka-esque to go back to the earlier
segment you tell me how you would
describe it
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chili sleep which
makes customizable climate controlled
sleep solutions to sleep better their
flagship products are the uhler sleep
system and the cube sleep system which
is what i have both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make them as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit if you wanted you
could go as hot as 115 degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chilly blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you twenty
percent off everything when you go to
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video